Hi everyone. Thank you. I'm very glad
to be here and it's a bit impressive.
That's also very presence to be able to
share this experience that was very um,
uh, a milestone in my life. First of all,
we are in September,
2016 and I'm working in the streets on
the pedestrian and the sidewalks and I
won't like to cross the streets.
So I come close to something that looks
like a pedestrian crossing and at the
exact moments I placed my foods and
the pavements a car or on blast through
there,
I jumped back to come back to the works
as a cow first by just right in front of
me.
I look and guess my art is a bit stamping
loudly and I realize that I've been
very close from a very important
accidents I haven't seen that's a,
there were a car coming by.
I hadn't seen that.
It was not a total pedestrian crossing.
In fact,
it was the middle of
the street intersection.
And if I hadn't seen all of this is
because I was blind and it is a picture of
me for one week in September,
2016 and you would wonder maybe why
someone would glide blindfold inside
himself.
Pretty sample.
I have a friend who is Brian
Charlie and she has an accident.
Maybe you know, it should take the
train quite often, you know, there is
sometimes a separation,
a gap between the train and the platform.
And if you don't mind, you
could fell. You can fall into.
And that's what happened.
She fell, Eh, it's a one,
an RF meter deep. Uh, she's fine today.
But at this moment it's very
moved me inside and I realize,
okay, I know you were in the
robotic field for years. Uh,
in the French liberty cap.
We train robots and we teach
them how to avoid obstacles gap.
How could we do it for
robots and not for blind?
It makes sense for me to try to transfer
a lot of a bit of technology that are
using in autonomous cars to
try to apply it to human being.
So that was the starting point.
And I figured out that if I
want to solve kind of problem,
I actually understand it.
So the,
the first abuse main that I found
was to try to live for one week,
Brian. It's like a simulation and
experience of cross. It's nuts.
Truly what Brian Pr person
will experiments because it's,
there are some factors that are uh,
that occurs only after a weeks and
especially if you are blind from,
from birth.
But it was very interesting
and if you want to try it,
I recommend you to try it for
only 20 minutes on 20 minutes.
It's very,
very instructive.
It was the worst week of my life
clearly and sort of a nightmare.
Um,
unsure SPEC.
And if I'm here today is to share you
three main discoveries I've made and three
discoveries that drives me today
or in all of my projects, uh,
including my startup.
First of all,
I would like to
guide you through a journey.
I will take this tool,
which is a white can.
You will close your eyes and I will be
your guide to discover as treats in the,
in the region, in the Paris area. So
close your eyes and listen to my voice.
You are on the sidewalk.
The wall from the building you would just
left is on your right and side on your
left.
You know that there is a road.
You all in your white Jen until the until
you're right and and you can feel the
pavement under your feet.
It's summer,
it's warm.
You're wearing a tee shirt and a light
win is bringing you the sounds of a
cafetiere Ross nearby.
It's a pleasant sensation you
decide to move on as you're working.
Your wife, Jen is doing. It's zigzag.
Dan's head of you in order to
protect you from any obstacle.
It's taping on the ground and
on the world on a regular basis.
By doing this,
you feel sure you can keep working
straightforward without veering off.
Everything is perfect.
Suddenly on your left ear
allowed roaring sound.
A car probably just passed by on the road,
so honestly the noise
was so defeat defunding.
You could have believe it was
driving right on the side work.
You go and work it.
You gain confidence and you
step away from the world.
Just a little in order
to move more freely.
When all of us students, you're
white Chen, it's something strongly
you surprised taping on this on thing
and then checking it with two hand.
It feels like a big tree trench
by being a bit more careful.
You realize that you can
eat a little birds singing.
They seem to have a lot of fun
right above your hand. Your ad,
this is,
it validates your theory of the tree.
You concluded that all of those nice
little birds must be playing on the
branches, which probably belonged
to the trees that are on the side.
Work on your left.
You decide to get around the tree by
sticking to the middle of the sidewalk and
you resume your journey.
Three steps, five steps.
Oh, you can. It's something
again and this time
it's a metal things.
The Sun is very sharp,
almost Chris timing light.
It's some,
it sounds like this thing
is something very light.
You're tapping on it and oh
yes. Oh yes, I know. What is it?
It's a chair.
Your cane is stuck and you've gotten
cage into a characteristic of a cafe.
You can open your eyes again.
How was it
pleasant or not?
This street is the street
just next to my home presence.
Yeah,
and I'd like to point to
point an interesting fact
in all of this description,
maybe you notice it,
there is,
there were no visual
element only sound smelling,
temperature touching,
no, no visual elements.
But I'm pretty sure everyone
here at the clear view,
a clear representation of the
streets of what's happening.
Interesting now,
interesting to notice that the brain is
able to create a mental representation
of something you've never
been there somewhere.
It never be on there and without
any education of how to build it.
And that's the first discovery for me.
During this one week,
I was first thinking that I would be
in the drug into darkness for one week,
but in fact I wasn't. If you should close
your eyes for more than a few minutes,
you realize that your brain starts to
put your memories in front of you and you
start moving around literally into
your past and into what you know.
So in every known areas I was able
to work through my memories was very
surprising
but of course this also have limitations.
When someone in,
for example in this room,
if you move something or if you are
working on the sidewalk and the scooter is
parked on the side work,
the amount of representation and
the reality is not in sync and your
visualization vanished so
you are not in the darkness.
My point is when I try to to
launch myself into new project,
I think first hour now what are you
doing? You've never been there. You have,
you don't.
You can't give a talk in English,
you're not good enough in English and
then I rethink and we thinking it's good
because we all have more
resources inside of us.
More that we tend to think
and when our limitations are rich.
For example,
when my mental transition is
not quite sync with the reality,
there is one option,
natural option,
ask for help and it's a good
idea to ask for help. It,
this is the second discovery I
would like to share with you.
You know the Darwin theory, I
think it's quite known, well known.
I think often it's a bit meaningless.
Misunderstood.
Darwin is about evolution and we often
think that evolution is a competition.
The best pieces will evolve and survive,
but in fact the kids who suck to success
is not competition is cooperation.
Why our society is successful today is
because we have been able to cooperate,
operate together and this is the
discovery I've made during this week.
I was not alone.
We're human being is capable
of an amazing capacity,
capability of empathy and compassion.
And I would like to share you
a quartz from a colleague of
mine in Palatine. In my startup,
we have a sort of tradition.
Every new colleague, I'm pretty,
I have to live 24 hours blind
to, to feel it. What it is,
it's not to mock is not to
to simulate anything more.
That's okay.
You join us and you have to to realize
deep inside you that we try to solve a
human problem.
We are not building a tech tool.
We are building something
that will help people.
And after this 24 hour experience,
it taught me this.
There's 24 hours in the dark re candid,
my face in human nature.
Okay.
We all have this um, situation. You are
in the mutual, in Paris on the morning,
everyone with the head down looking at
the screen of the smart phones and we
avoid eye contact the most as we can.
And often we can wonder if
something very bad happened.
Would someone raise up the Ed the
head to look at me and ask me?
I can assure you that in a
distressful situation, every way,
everything changes,
everything changes and leave quite a lot
of distressful situations during this
week into gives you a bit
of context. I leave, um,
30 kilometer away from Paris,
about one hour and a half, uh,
to,
to commute morning and in the nights and
during this week I would like to do a
regular walks with
scheduling meetings in Paris,
in everywhere.
And of course I got lost a lot
and one of this expensive, it's pretty,
pretty interesting. I was in the,
in the station a lost and I was
very cushion with everything.
When you're blind, you very caution
with everything you listen to. Uh,
to paper on the fruit.
You listen two steps from Ozark persons,
you are try to figure
out what's around you.
I'm asking hello, is there, I
knew anybody or I need help.
And I uh, a young lady not far 10. Yes,
I'm coming.
She's coming to help me and she
does something very surprising.
She thinks my end,
well not the very tactile,
that team in our society don't free
do you have this situation where big
elevator empty the drawers open,
man,
step in and your works
cross to u s m stop ear.
She was centimeter away from your face.
Did you have this acquired moments?
And as I said in this twist for moments,
everything changes.
When she took my end,
I was nuts.
I was not, I was happy.
In fact, I was happy.
It was very full of tenderness and I feel
like a wave of energy coming from Er.
And I'm very glad because I recalled
this moment and would like to show you,
I had the Gopro camera on the torso.
So this is the station and
we can see the the girl.
Yeah we've,
it's fun
and I'm waiting and she took
my hand and in straight.
Interesting is probably I
would in a regular situation,
never talked to her.
Also person she offers me ALP
naturally those guys very,
very nice.
I was again lost
and maybe we would never
have course it's,
there were
often people love about them.
Self willing to help
me and a bit a quality.
Trying to take my aunt to
move me often pushing me.
Not a good idea
but definitely people were very,
very nice to me.
And it's,
I think it's good to remember that human
being have a lot of good thing deep
inside maybe in our
society. So bits, Hi Eden.
And because we are all stressed,
we are all in lack of time we go
fast but in distress for moments,
it's good to know that we
can count on each other.
And when I,
I know start a project,
I often try to re to rethink
what are my capabilities.
But I also try to think that in all
situation there will be someone ready to
help.
I think it's very relaxing in
important to get to keep it in line.
And first,
third one tell discovery is the most
important one and important one.
A bit of background details.
When I jump into this week,
I had clearly no idea
about what would happen.
I had one or two hours of
training with the wide chain.
We've with a friend of me
of my and then a jumping.
But
after bumping into walls,
bumping into and fire hydrants,
you know,
you need 93 remembers
it. Uh, getting lost.
I think the feeling of
being abandoned and yes,
stepping into a dog poop
took the abuse with it.
Smelling this disgusting smelling and
feeling the passengers reproached full
look at me and finally being run over,
nearly run over by a car.
I knew exactly what it would be.
It was the first day
and trust me on the second
morning when I had to to go out,
I was terrified. And even
today when I look at the, the,
the recording from this week,
I can feel my stomach because
it was very terrifying.
I think it's kind of traumatic to do it.
So as I said,
20 minutes,
not more,
but that is said there is a powerful,
powerful discovery bi in this
on the morning I take my shoes,
I take the camera,
I closed the door.
I think the inviter I go in front of
the drew of my building and then I was
stuck.
Petrified can do any more moved and I
don't know how much time does it take,
but at certain points when I
opened the door and I step out,
everything vanished.
I mean
the fear tends to stop you to
stop me and when you jump out,
when you jump, the FIA is still
here, but the power is vanished.
That's why I like to say the first
step is always the more difficult one,
but also the more important one.
And it runs for everything,
I think projects but also
spots and everything.
Immobility,
polarize.
Whereas movements liberates action.
Chicks out fear.
And that's good to know.
I unfounded in panda or startup,
we have a motto,
it's the French word salts,
which mean leap English or jump.
And the first letter from from salt is s,
which stands for sacrifice.
It's a strong word,
but a first step.
The first leap is always a sacrifice,
but it's what's cost to Jen and I was,
I also like the motor from the
first RPA or military in French.
It's a Kiehl's Gal.
[inaudible] win.
This is it you,
you'd ask you when you jump and
direction chicks funeral outs.
So this is the point
I've been trying to make.
We all have dreams.
Maybe it's taking a trip around the world.
Start Your own business,
take a new artistic ob,
take on a sprouting challenge,
volunteer with an Ngo,
even going vegetarian,
tested, whatever the challenge is.
I know, believe that this I have.
If I think it's enough and it's come to
my mind quite often I have to rethink to
stop and to rethink why
I am not acting on it.
And if we are unnecessary,
if I am honest,
always the reason why I don't move,
it's sphere only fear.
That's why the first step, the first
step is for me, very important.
The first step is always a sacrifice,
but let's,
let's make a parent is ear about dreams.
I like dreams.
I think them quite seriously
and I know drink in France,
a lot of persons.
You remember some famous dream
Martin Luther King for example.
A dream can influence a lot of people
in dreams. Always funny. It's
fascinating, fascinating me.
Maybe you have been called a dreamer in
the past I've been and I think there is
a huge difference between
dreaming and planning.
I can dream all of my life going for a
trip around the room and doing nothing.
I can plan to go for a trip to trip
around the world and starting it by typing
on Google how to go for
a trip around the world.
The difference is that an
issue if I dream today,
I tried to dream seriously with an of
power when the NF conviction passion to
turn them into an PR,
into plans that we'll be able to,
to inspire millions of people.
I think that's the the most
wonderful thing with dreams.
In conclusion,
I embarked in this and virtual
without knowing what I was doing.
Clary as far as a,
not fun at the beginning but in fact
I've discovered a lot of our things on me
and users and those three discoveries are
not driving me for all of the projects
I can.
I can lead first.
I have more resource in me and we all
have more resource in our that what re
tends to think.
This is one of my principal today and I
encourage you when you want to start a
project to rethink about your capability.
Often we can do more to
corporation is key to success.
For me it's the most important discovery.
We are not alone and we can choose
to be this helper for someone that is
building something new that is
leading a project and I've decided to,
whenever I am,
wherever I do,
whatever I do to be this and to help
someone that will maybe contact me and I
knew that we'd be able to and some someone
else on the project. I have to learn.
I had to lead
and self discovery.
The first step is always the
most important one and the
most difficult one. Also.
Um, I keep fighting against me
against procrastination, against,
um, my tends to put off
my dream till tomorrow,
but I take them very seriously and I
take all my efforts to convert my dream
into plants and often
sometime it creates a startup.
I'm convinced that some of us today
we'll take that leap of faith that
will trigger a major discoveries,
major initiative that we positively
impacted millions of people.
So I would like to conclude with a quote
from Mr Chak noise that I'm sure you,
you love
like me and you said
there really is a hero in all of us.
We've all been designed by God to be a
blessing to many an arrow to some bud.
There is only one way to go there.
Do I think we can choose to
be around starting today?
Thank you.
Yeah,
I left.
So I like to have some questions about
the credits cause I can talk about your
experience best support, inspiring.
That's what it would feel like.
How he's bored. Okay. Up Cook meat.
Yes.
Um,
Bhanda is today to the sixth
iteration of the product.
First of all,
we were designing sort of new
class sort of gloves and you know,
when you prototype something you'll
give it to someone and you say, okay,
it's good. No, it's good, it's bad.
You just, it's just nice to you.
And so we tried a lot and
now we are building uh,
headsets which goes around the neck.
We have a little camera rotten.
He came around my,
like a drone one in the side,
which is about to record.
I'll take pictures of
Jennifer environments and to
explain it to the blind user.
The idea is to,
um,
two l per persons in walk areas,
scores,
public transportations by reading signs,
uh,
papers and two by identifying objects,
recovering them.
If they fall under Ron of issue.
Dex Can,
or I don't know how your
desk is clean or not,
but you can then ask him on
that to find an item that you,
that you have to take.
But the idea behind it is,
this is Paula today.
But my goal is not to create like this.
My goal is to help people to,
to regain their autonomy.
Maybe tomorrow it will be something
totally different and I'm fine with it and
hopefully one day will be useless
because if we do our walk a call,
actually we will be able to,
to teach person to leave without powder
because it's kind of a reeducation
process. Yes. Great question.
So I had never thought of it. When
you, it, it seems almost obvious
to your self driving cars and it almost
seems obvious compliant people would
have this and I know they don't cause I
don't know any blind person who has the
similar technology to self driving car.
Did you find other projects doing things
like this when you started or is it
really just uh,
yeah,
a few projects,
most of them came from laboratories and
the goal is not to have a project behind
just a demonstration of African Jew.
The challenge is to adapt
what's the science says,
what are the result of experiments
into an affordable products for a teeny
market. And this challenge, uh,
explains what the,
why the result,
not that much project today and not
that much project, especially for kids.
And what we know today is kids
is the key because the brain,
how it's evolved, the kief phase
is between six to 10 years old.
If you act on this particular
stage of development,
you can take a giant leap
for the future of the person.
And if you miss it or
if you try to act later,
you will be on a sort of transactional
item and you will be dependent of the
tool. And even if it's a good
tool, it's more to be autonomous.
And our idea is to teach
people personnel to,
to go to fishing without
giving fish all the time.
Oh, do you think help you
pursue that objective?
You must know what our services,
we have media that you will have also
many other projects about cloud or
do you think we could do more
to help you to, to reach you on?
I think one of the key points
is a technological, uh,
artificial intelligence is one
of the center of conduct today.
And we know that Google is doing a lot
of research in this field in particular
in computer vision.
So that could be um,
an important step in forward
if we were able to yes.
To share resources we are using also
Google products and then of course there
are are are always the um,
the capability to generate trust around
you and especially true for a tech
startup in this early stage.
Do you think we keep
your users stuck into uh,
like your product or already
helping them to uncover more sense
and the surroundings?
Yes. This is the question.
It's more like a, what do you add that
to your situation that being bled?
There is a project that
he's here and helps you
downloads of justification and explanation
needed to zip into this question.
But few key points.
First,
the brain is designed to use to,
to use military stories.
At the same time,
universities use only one issue.
See you tends to ear issue
smell you send to local to,
to find the location of the, the
smell always. It's a combination.
And even for the proprioception,
when you touch something with
your fit or rocks together.
So you can't just replace one sense
by another because if you do so you,
you are, um, action, the
brain natural working.
So the idea is to work the same
way the brain is naturally working.
And if you do so by
training a person on panda,
you won't try needs for
natural situation also.
And then the,
the second idea is to show that what's,
uh,
the feedbacks that came that come from
GFI months and to help person to seem to
be in control of the feedbacks that comes.
For example, panda is always sleeping.
It's not proactive,
it's only reaction.
So we have stimulation to help,
especially kids to move.
But it's always the person that will
ask for information and process it.
It's important and unimportant topic
that we have to address one day is this.
Um,
this issue with blind kids have not the
simulator the stimulation from the eyes.
You see children doing a lot of mess
when they are a little because the
experiments mater motorization
of their muscle, um, uh,
precision of the movement.
And this is called the,
this is creating feedback loops between
the muscles and what you perceive of
Shimmer. Sir, if you
don't see your movements,
you lose a lot of
calibration of your own body.
And this calibration is important
because it will help you to be more
comfortable in the world, in your
move, in your social interaction.
So one important thing we have to achieve
with powder is to try to recreate sort
of artificial,
um,
feedback loops that will add p person
to calibrate themselves and then have
fully panda will be more and more,
less and less useful.
Of course,
there are a lot of things that you
won't be able to, to do reading,
especially I don't see fighting, uh,
faces when they are far from you.
But for the war majority of movements,
the idea is to motivates person,
giving it side give, give
them, um, success. Also 12,
10 through to go forward throw photo.
And by the way,
that's why we're working with Ubisoft
on this topic to create a sort of video
game experience, but not to do
again, but experience of, um,
of winning,
getting success in the real,
in a virtual environment to
then translate to reality.
Long answer,
one question from doing that week
that you were buying, were you,
did you,
uh,
I'm sure you've identified a lot of
problems that are not technology problems
that can be sold somewhere else. Like,
like for instance, if I'm buying at night,
I'm in a metro station, I have no
idea. Like where's the exit? Right.
What other things did you, um, from
all of those problems that you address,
did you,
I dunno,
contact areas to try to solve
any of those or did you have any
yes, Donald Otoc of, uh,
projects in the public public
area and pubic companies.
Um, a lot of initiative. I think the,
the goal would be to synchronize,
synchronize everyone. Two guys are,
and this is happening
monthly,
we've sought of federations of nonprofit
organization with a sort of cluster
between companies,
between startups.
And there is also a big motivation from
biggest companies due to low constraints
and you two are so um,
what's is called the responsibility of
the companies for the wellbeing for the,
for the implication.
So I think it's going to do good,
do good direction and I won't
solve all the program by myself,
but like in robotics, in robotics,
some people think we will,
I have autonomous
humanoid robots from one,
one metro from my side for example.
I don't believe in it. I am,
I think we will,
I have a lot of senior robots,
very specific specific shit and dedicated
to the mission I dream for in men.
We drove out like in the movies,
but I think it's more efficient to
have tennis specialized workers.
And it's the same way.
Found this problem of a visual impairment.
Can't remember where it was. I read
an article a long time ago, uh,
a blind person who could, we'd ride
a bike, think he might be American.
Yes. You know about this. I'm
curious if you know anything.
Cause I remember there were some theories
in the article that maybe because his
parents and he said,
just go ride a bike.
They didn't credit doing things even
though maybe it's a little bit dangerous.
Their attitude was,
well all kids do things that are a little
bit dangerous and maybe this was part
of his ability to do all these things. Do
you, have you found anything about that,
that maybe doing more
things somehow affects,
I think I'm not the most qualified to,
to know what seems to, to teach
a kid, especially a blind one.
But, um, there is no general generic
change are always different cases.
And I'm a friend,
I've been friends with a blind person
and he's blind fro from his childhood and
he's able to, to do the
echolocation. So you,
you clicked your aunts or you make
some with your mouth and you can, uh,
estimate the distances, the, the area,
when we go into a room, it takes
an insane telling me, okay,
there is no one here.
It's about a 20 meters square.
It's very strong.
And is also um,
a flight period plane that he said,
uh,
I think we can do more to,
to help kids to,
to use their own abilities differently.
Parents,
yes,
but he tried to challenging and especially
again because they are not so many
and that's a good and bad news because uh,
you can't mass projects
something it really,
Cruz also could cost a lot but there
is a real need that that's that's the
opposite side.
Yes.
That's something that you can do.
We've just scratched the surface.
But do you go,
this is nuts to especially do face
recognition because you have the voice and
the person doesn't need to have explicitly
the name of the person she's talking
about is talking about but some
situations are a bit awkward.
For example,
you are in a a cafe coffee machine with
other people and one by one they leave
and you,
you know,
alone annual continued talking alone and
it's quiet quite a common situation in
companies.
It's a bit shaming for the
person and we can fix it.
Exactly. I don't see fine person,
but we can only say, okay,
there were three people then through
and then no one and I can still hear the
voice of my users.
So I will input a teeny vibration to okay,
check the reason why in front of you.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly.
With your,
from my weekend sprints. Okay. Yes.
The remapping of the brain is something
that could occur very strongly only for
the kids if,
sure.
Child blind injured child
when you are adults. Um,
there isn't,
it's not that strong.
It's more something anecdotic but in fact,
indeed for the kids it's very
important. And I have, uh,
I know a software developer
who is blind and deaf.
You have the both and Isabel to read
two lines of a book at the same time and
understand the same amount
because he is a bit listen to you
because the, the is
blind for, for the birth.
And so he's about to do,
Brian is remapping.
But on the other side there is a lot of
damages on the appropriate section and
what we call a sensors calibration.
For example, if you have,
um,
speakers all around you and I can,
I will move a sound or injection and
we'll ask you to raise your hand when the
sound is moving.
For a blind person,
the gap is more,
is more important.
Jangle of detection is more
important than for a sighted person.
That's something that you can compensate
and reeducate and it's important to
reeducate and don't.
I were thinking that the remapping
of their brain was a great,
like a Soviet power,
but in fact it's like of
mitigate, mitigate. I
don't know to say that.
Okay. Yes. Does it answer?
Okay. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Yes,
thank you very much.